hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
[Music]
baby that intro takes me back to the
summer 2020. hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage
the show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find if they grow
up classy
or if they're a piece of garbage i'm
your host holy coming at you on a nice
crisp fall
day here in the east village new york
city it feels like they're shooting e.t
outside i [ __ ] love it man i love it
uh my jacket does not fit in
traditional sense but that is neither
here nor there i can't do the hawaiians
after labor day
so i'm going with the hawaiian uh
athletic jacket
that fit me last christmas but that's
neither here nor there
my co-host coming at you from right next
to me gang you know the drill
he cooks the books he keeps everybody in
line it keeps the irs
and the feds and the cia off our back
the next time you're reaching for a best
pal do yourself a favor
you go ahead and make it a kippy give it
up for kevin james ryan everybody hey
hey gang happy to be here thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube you can
subscribe there as well
those numbers are through the [ __ ]
roof
uh also you can sign up for gas digital
network using promo code ayg
you get to save a couple of bucks every
month we get to make a couple of bucks
every month it's a win-win for everybody
happy to be here yes sir and gang we
could not be more excited and i know
because this is a highly requested guest
we have today
and i'll tell you what this rap sheet
right here credits
we got a little [ __ ] star power a
little bit of juice coming make that
cappuccino decaf extra foam kid
all right gang uh our guest today is an
extremely funny stand-up comedian
and actor as an actor she has appeared
in the jim gaffigan show
kevin can wait the comedian with mr
robert
de niro crashing ramy the king of staten
island
okay as a stand-up comedian sit back get
[ __ ] comfortable
this is gonna take me a minute let's go
here we go we're going back last comic
standing
last call with carson daly the tonight
show with jay
leno twice the og oh g
all right we're talking shoulder pads
big suits
by the way looks like you got shoulder
pads in right now to be honest with them
they're wide receiver pads all right we
got the apprentice
the apprentice wanda sykes hilarious
gotham comedy live the nightly show at
midnight what's your [ __ ] deal
this week at the comedy cellar lights
out with david spade
i will now turn
the tonight show with jimmy fallon
tournament of last on tbs
and the new series stars in the house
and she also has her own special out
called talking to myself presented by
mr bill burr ladies and gentlemen the
big question about his mind today is she
garbage i don't know that but she's a
[ __ ] hell of a stand-up comedian and
she's goddamn successful and i'm sure
she's got a little bit of cash on her
because she bought a brand new [ __ ]
car today
and we're gonna hear all about it give
it up for jessica kirsten everybody oh
thank you hi that's so
nice so happy to have you here i'm so
happy to be here i know i've had to
cancel a couple times and i apologize to
you
we've had to do the same so we're glad
it finally worked out yeah it's your
fault
how was leno was he cool was he handsy
what's the deal he fingered me but he
was
very he was nice so it doesn't matter
real quick yeah yeah yeah yeah
buddy thanks so much for coming in thank
you i no he was actually incredibly nice
he came backstage twice and talked to me
and was
really sweet he was that's one guy i've
always wanted to meet
really i think just i grew up watching
him yeah a girl watching him and then
conan
yeah so i've always wanted to meet him
yeah and they they you know they're all
pretty
i mean some of them are known to be
dicks but most of them are
really nice yeah i want to meet the guy
that played him on the nightly show
remember that
that movie no i remember it but i can't
picture who that is
he looks just like him all right that
would have hit if everybody would have
said
he did he went for a deep cut with the
nightly choke can you edit that out
yeah that's at four minutes and thirty
one kill everybody in the livestream
yeah we've been really trying to have
you on for a long time we're so glad
that we got you here
um what is the what is the back story of
jessica kirsten where did you you're a
jersey galaxy yes
yeah yes i grew up in south orange new
jersey okay
and a little bit of cash down there
right yes a little bit
in my part of the town yeah i lived in
an
um area called newstead which everyone
called justin
so not religious though anytime people
think that they're like oh you must i
was not brought up religious
just uh reforms just culturally jewish
yes
yes and then um i my parents were
married they got divorced when i was 13
and my mom got remarried to uh zach
braff's father
that's right so there's four kids there
there were two of us just my sister and
i
so it became six of us from scratch
zach like the zac bryant zach braff was
your step brother yes we did it we did a
q a
together last night it was fun yeah we
did a for
charity i mean we made money but it was
for he's like
ask for 20 grand jesus christ he's got
the kind of money to where it's like if
it ain't if it ain't 20 don't even come
at me yeah i'm not getting out of bed
right for for 20 minutes i was like oh
my god i'm not used to it
coming from a comedian like 20 grand i
made that's what i made in [ __ ] 92.
right that's what i mean yeah that's
this year for krogan
wait a minute was he would see an actor
when he was a child
actor he was nine and i was 15 when our
parents started dating and then we
we lived together when he was 13 and i
was i don't remember
18 or so wow okay yeah and then uh
and then my dad got remarried to a woman
who was much younger and they had two
kids so now
i had a full sister and then i had four
i had four steps and two halves
that's one of everything you're getting
a psychic i know and you so you live
with your mom
yeah i lived with my mom with your mom
yes then she got remarried
yes all right and then those other kids
move in the house right what was that
like well some were in college already
it was it
actually i'm very lucky because everyone
really got along like we really did
it was like a brady bunch situation it
was yeah and then i
also lived at my dad's half the time so
i was one of those kids who like lived
out of a suitcase
that's why being a stand-up has been
fine for me
i literally lived out of a suitcase for
years so he's remarried
new kids your mom's remarried new kids
how many kids were
in in the in the breaths um so the
breaths were
four three three step brothers and a
stepsister but
he was five years old six years younger
than yeah he was the youngest so there's
eight of you total
like if you clean out the half and the
step and you right
yes damn co-mingled i know
and i grew up with one sister until i
was a teenager so it was
weird so high school was literally like
the brady bunch yes
that's crazy yeah because we were two
girls and they were one girl and three
boys so when we got
all got together it was three boys and
three girls yeah jewish brady buncher
the brady punch the brady bunch
[Laughter]
first episode they fire alice she was
stealing
because she's white um yeah
guadalupe that's awesome uh
how often did you stay with your dad was
it like weekends or what was it
i would go a week and then another week
so that was hard because i would get
used to one house and then i wouldn't
want to go to the other house
but i wouldn't want to go where you
would i i would get like
sometimes if there was an argument i'd
want to go through yeah i think that'd
be pretty good it's a nice out
yeah it depended it depended on what was
going on like sometimes i would want to
get out and sometimes i wouldn't want to
leave because they lived in two separate
towns
far away yeah they were like 10 minutes
from each other same with me that was
the same school district
no what'd you go to two different
schools no i went to columbia in
maplewood new jersey and my dad lived in
melbourne which was like
literally seven minutes away so he would
just drive me to school every morning
okay all right yeah i did that same
thing you did getting dropped off by
yeah by your dad every every [ __ ]
it was we did monday tuesday at my mom's
wednesday thursday my dad's on
weekends flip flops i know i gotta say
like it was okay but it did [ __ ] me up
like i've learned recently that a lot of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
i did but i mean there's no way of
getting around it if the people need to
get divorced
sure now did you have your own room in
each house yes
your own designated room yes sound like
when you weren't there someone else was
staying there
your posters your everything your diary
under the
under the match i had two i know and
then like they would try to jack them up
so that i'd want to stay with one longer
you know they
that was the good thing i got you get
[ __ ] out you learn to play the two
against the middle
right i got a bb gun a mini that's like
bike
casino right there
give me some chips to play on the house
yeah did you like one better than the
other one house better than the other
probably changed maybe at times you did
better yeah
your stepdad or your real dad well your
mom at my mom's
i was near my friend i was closer to my
friends
and i could you know do different things
like smoke pot and drink more
but at my dad's i had more fun and i had
more
stuff there like more toys and um
then i did fun stuff with them so it was
i don't know
they both were good for different
reasons yeah here's a i have a question
uh and this specifically for children of
divorce who took you out to dinner
more for both of you dad your dad right
your dad yeah
yeah that's the way you win the kid over
i know looking at the ground round on a
thursday night the ground
yeah we went to a place called gyros in
northeast philly
smoking section all day it was
that is garbage yeah it was real trash i
love that hell of a chicken finger shout
out to gear
yeah i don't know what because my one of
my best friends growing up his dad was
divorced and
the kids lived with the dad dude we used
to go he was eating out
i don't know what he did he was a lawyer
or something every night
and it'd be like every every two or
three days in the summer they go you
want to come to
me and my dad it's like [ __ ] yes i
know you don't go
out to eat as much when they're not
divorced that's so true
there's a home there's like a fiber in
the home you go back everybody's there
yeah but when it's all kind of broken up
it's like where would he take you
where would be the the going out spot oh
we'd go out for like great burgers and
you know go into the city a lot
which my mom and i didn't do yeah he
would take me to class that's huge
i know yeah i would have stumbled up my
room with my mom
airbnb for a couple of bucks mom there's
an asian family stay in the weekend
me and dad are going to melons so uh we
can't make it back we're going to get a
room at the plaza
and he would take me shopping a lot you
know he did he knew what he was doing
yeah yeah
he also felt guilty because he was
[ __ ] a secretary but then he get
married to his secretary yeah he did
wow yeah she was his secretary and then
they ended up together and they're they
my dad just passed but they they had
been together for oh my god 35 years
okay which is rare yeah i would i mean
he met someone 19 years younger
hot woman you know he was charismatic
but
they stayed together which is odd yeah i
was the same thing mine was like the
bookkeeper
my dad and then they're no longer
together i don't think yeah so it's
yeah it didn't it doesn't doesn't always
it doesn't last a lot
but it did wow yeah i think that's what
keeping keeping marriages together that
a lot of guys don't get secretaries
you know what i mean because they don't
have a good idea so true you know now a
lot
yeah yeah secretary now
yeah that's true what do you do i'm i'm
i work for my husband
i keep his books yeah and make sure he's
not [ __ ] anybody in the apartment
in the office i watch what he does
what did your parents do yeah what did
your pop do so my mom was a there
is a therapist okay so she that's fun
yeah she saw clients in the house my
whole life that's another reason why
what
yes that's always so that's a big thing
it's amazing put a pin
in that yeah so so we um so i didn't
love being there for that reason after
school because i had to be quiet all the
time
and then my dad was a business guy and
and when he was with karen you know
after we were grown up he made it huge
he he
he got into manufacturing nail polish so
he made essie and opie all the nail
polishes so
yeah yeah so he did very well with his
and his new kids
lived a different life than we lived
that's always weird the dichotomy of
yeah when did you lose when did you lose
your room
at his house that's a good question
um when the kids were born when the kid
like i mean i didn't need it i was out
of the house at that point i was in
college but
yeah then they they moved and then it
was their two kids
you know their rooms yeah yeah that
happened to me too
they were like michael's getting your
[ __ ] i'm like all right i'll see you at
thanksgiving
take it easy hey kippy you want that
race car man
yeah put some 20s on that thing oh man
mom was a therapist that's my heart
still is mom sees zoom
clients all the time now she's amazing
she really is um i mean i talk about
this a lot but she
she's driven me crazy my whole life i
adore her but it's nuts
i gotta like julie shimmer who's a
therapist yeah that's like double
dipping yeah
yeah that is like extreme anxiety and
boundaryless it's so funny i grew up i
grew up in at philadelphia
obviously philadelphia you know the
northeast it's like where all the and
the
west coast is where all the jewish
people live like there's no there's no
jews in the middle of the country really
right and i grew up with all jewish
friends in a jewish like a jewish
area and i meet people that only have
met jewish people in their like 20s when
they moved to new york and i'm like
to know the anxiety of a jewish person
is like it's so
right it's the the the neurotic aspect
it's it's insane well that happened with
my wife because she was brought up
catholic uh
you know uh irish italian mothers [ __ ]
up yeah i'm irish
right but it's just the it's different
it's very similar but it's different in
the way like the neurosis with jewish
people is really crazy yeah i mean
just we do it as shame we take it to
shame yes you guys
there's no shame you'll just you know
it's just all it's all neurotic yeah i'm
very shameful
you are always i'm so sorry
jesus you're really bringing the heat
this episode
i feel bad can we give him a b12 shot or
something what do you mean yeah
so shameful i hate the zinger about
alice
he's pretty good i'm told that nightly
no there's so much shame
there's so much shame and and yeah i see
it i see it all the time
it's crazy um
i'm interested in the i've never known
anybody
that had a parent who ran their practice
out of the house it's fascinating
actually but i've been to a couple like
you know in the suburbs that's you know
usually where you went to the dentist or
where you went to the orthodontist or
whatever the dentist in a suburban
you know suburban neighborhood and my
therapist used to have when i was in
college they sent me to a therapist for
add or something like that
and um his practice was at his house
and it was always weird like being in
there and like the kids are out there
like the wife's out there grilling and
[ __ ]
like i'm in there [ __ ] crying about
so many stories i mean
did you just hear people like screaming
and crying yes i would sit on the stairs
and get high
i would get high and then sit on the
stairs and listen like i
said no like people like screaming at a
chair because like that was
their father all kinds of [ __ ] yeah
but when i was growing up there i mean i
sound like i'm 90 but there were no
beepers or cell phones there wasn't so i
had to answer the door
i was like her secretary i answered the
door and then she never wrote any
clients down so they would just show up
and i'd always feel guilty like
feel bad for them and i'd be like i
guess she'll be home soon but would you
like something to drink be home
i got a couple of three sons of yeah she
wasn't home no
she she was she played a fan she would
she would forget them a lot so they
would and sometimes two would show up at
the same time
and they would sit in the den and wait
and like the housekeeper's daughter
would be in there i swear to god and
they would all watch cartoons together
so i just walk in and see like bianca
the house
the housekeeper's daughter and like two
of my mom's clients like la la
and then i had to be quiet she was
helping other people but i was suffering
like i was going through so much [ __ ]
but she'd be like susan's coming and
she's having a hard time
so i'm gonna need you to be quiet i'm
like you have to put a lid on your [ __ ]
the cat but good luck to susan
it's amazing having to grow up like that
being quiet all the time
i think it's why i'm so loud on stage i
love a microphone i just want to scream
i wouldn't be able to handle that now it
was hard
and you can't interrupt them so you know
when you're a teenager can i go to this
person's house i need this for school
like i could never
interrupt her so it was not easy it was
not easy
it wasn't how come she didn't get a
little spot in professional center how
much could the rent have been
you know what i mean well it was you
know people did that to stay home
and take care of their kids but the
whole thing was her with clients all day
anyway so it didn't even like the point
that she was home was
there was no he wasn't really there yet
right yeah yeah how separate was the
was it literally just they came in your
front door because most players have a
side entrance
yeah there was two houses so
the first one was they came this was a
lot they came through the front door
and they went into an office when they
walked in
[Laughter]
take your shoes off that was like where
the you know the foyer was like the
kitchen was right there i mean it was
that was
in the house yeah that's it from the
house when you're a little kid and
they're strangers
oh my god you're laying on the stairs
looking like trying to catch a
reflection like what the [ __ ] are these
people
yeah yeah some guy be like hi i'm here
to see your mother i'm like are you sure
you're not here to see me
like it was so frightening but then the
second house they went in through the
garage and then the side thing
so that was at least a little bit of a
buffer i know but talk about garbage the
garage entrance for this i know also
yeah if you're a therapy you've got to
go through a garage
just hear that door going on i'd hear
the door that's the door would give me
so much anxiety because i knew someone
was coming and then i would be like mom
like she was gone forever if you're
walking by a tractor to get to your
therapist you need better insurance for
sure
and then she was an art therapist like
that's how she started so there would be
like tin foil structures on the phone
like did everyone have a meeple macaroni
what is happening
there'd be traces of people's bodies and
like i just
it was fascinating i mean that's yeah
kooky
i love it yeah none of that at dad's
though i'll tell you that no
my dad would i cannot even believe they
ever were together he is was so black
and white
macho like conservative i mean it just
he'd you don't talk about felix
like he'd ha he'd ask me if he wanted to
know who i
how i was he would say how's your head
that was not my father
how's your head you okay jesse real soft
guy yeah
my mom would be like talk about it just
keep sharing and
i i can't even believe they were
together for 18 years jesus those old
school
guys man they they bury a lot you're
right and they they lose it at some
point their capacity
to bury it and function and seem normal
on the outside and seem like they're
having an okay time
you know i've been out to dinner with my
dad a couple of times seems like he's
having fun
but they really man they just oh it's
like 50 years of [ __ ] just
layer after layer oh when he was dying
my dad passed in april um he had cancer
wasn't coveted but
he was so inward i mean that's really
interesting you just said that because
he
you know most i've been around
unfortunately other my stepfather my
stepsister other people
and he was just very close with it and
like you know
he did not want to be vulnerable and it
was so interesting
my uncle one of my uncles was the same
way he got cancer
and it uh got him pretty quick and i
remember like when we had to like go and
say goodbye to him they were used to he
was in hospice care at his house
and like i went in there and he was
always like you know that exactly what
you're talking about like just tough on
the outside but
you know but funny and charming and all
that stuff and like i went in there i'm
like i'm bawling my eyes out and like
he's barely conscious and i'm like
squeezing his hand and he's like
you gotta let me go oh jesus
that's what i went through hardcore talk
about demons oh dude
let him take me he was a rock i said i
love you and he's like i love you i love
you love you how many times you're gonna
say i love you
meanwhile he's a skeleton and like
[ __ ] himself
and he passed like two days later right
get out of here he mocked me
he's enough already he's like how much
you're gonna say come on just get me my
[ __ ] apple sauce
go get that cute nurse yeah holy [ __ ]
go get that cute nurse where's debbie at
oh man that is something and where'd you
go to school
i went to university of maryland okay
underground and then i went to nyu for a
master's in social work but then i
became a
comedian so i didn't practice social
work
um which is better because it was too
depressing for me i
couldn't handle it i don't know how
people do it social work yeah
yeah i ca i couldn't do it so depressing
yeah just like inheriting other people's
problems and not being really being able
to fix them you're just watching it
right and i take on like i'm pr you guys
are probably
very similar your comics i mean i take
on people's energy like i can
i would i get sad around people who are
sad i mean i i'm trying to work on it
but it's
it's hard for me to just be around that
and hear these horrible stories and just
not be right not be able to really help
yeah yeah it's tough i used to get sad
when i was a kid and we'd go to
mcdonald's during the day
and it'd always be like one or two old
and i wanted to go again at night and
they said no
like you just missed breakfast
old guys just sitting there by
themselves smoking this used to [ __ ]
bum me out
well that's because you're sensitive
like most performers are like that yeah
we're very sensitive people but it was
also i feel like in a selfish way
because i just wanted to enjoy my burger
it's like i don't see look at this
[ __ ] old guy mom let's take this to
the [ __ ] car
get my big breakfast and hit the bricks
yeah that's what i feel when i go to
like when i'm around amputees i'm like
god damn it can't you just get your legs
back so i can have a better day
you know what i mean you're walking
through a casino you're just like oh
that is casinos are tough
i think casinos are as bad it's like
medical center
it's really it's really true clerk
they're hooked in by a card with like a
[ __ ] thing hanging they're smoking
they have
they're riddled with cancer yeah
everything's part of the little close
enough it's like a hospital
come on god give me seven and they're
like rubbing and they're rubbing and
then like they're coughing and lighting
up cigarettes
it's so upsetting it really is i was i
think i might have said this before i
was i was in ac doing shows and
afterwards i was like i'll go play the
tables and i'm sitting at a table
and this [ __ ] mutant this guy
literally just collapses next to me
faints falls backwards
and nobody batted an eye no no nobody
moved
i know and i go with this guy and
they're like yeah they'll come around
they see him on the camera they'll come
get him they just came and scooped them
up
nothing ever happened isn't that
unbelievable the
the the price of life and the tropicana
at 2am is pretty
low i've made videos there where i'll be
at a slot machine like
you know it's like someone first of all
your videos are insane
thanks for doing some of the stuff you
do i know i
i was just watching when you were at a
restaurant shoving naskins in your mouth
or something i'm like how does she have
the balls to do this
that was with jim brewer at the table
and those were his kids laughing isn't
that funny we were at a wedding
well you and brewer are awesome oh my
god i love him we were at a wedding
together yeah but i
i i sometimes i have these hidden camera
videos where i'll sit in a slot machine
be like how am i going to pay the rent
all this stuff it's so people get so
freaked out oh yeah
those are sad and so people getting
lottery tickets man
with the little pencils like guys
breaking out like like a hundred dollars
like chris
twenties let me get three nine eight
straight box four nine four the number
yeah you're standing in front of
gatorade like this isn't the action
get the [ __ ] out of here that's exactly
what the place is by me
in long island where i live these people
are in there all day just sitting at
these tables
you know filling out with a little
pencil a little piece of the paper
that's been in their pocket for like
four weeks they hold on to it and
scratch it off
about the places where they have the tv
and there's some kind of game going on
isn't that kino oh that's bad i think
that's worse
he knows worse those guys get laid like
what's that
doubt buy horses
i'm gonna go over the 7-eleven play a
little keno be back in a little bit
what's your birthday what's your
birthday again give me a number one to
ten come in hitting everybody
in the store one two three one and also
also two those daily numbers like the
three dollar like the three digit
numbers and stuff if you hit those
because i used to work at acme they said
sell the lottery tickets yeah
and they would come people would come in
and spend you know 50 bucks a day
trying to hit a number for two years and
then they finally hit one and it's like
it's like 800 bucks it's not like
they're not 100 they're not winning 10
grand or something yeah but if you're
betting 50 a week yeah that's a day
sometimes because they're daily numbers
they're just hemorrhaging money and
they're like well i won two
two weeks ago it's the action baby
everyone lies about the money too
if you asked me when i was gambling for
a while if you said how much you lose oh
thank god
you
i could sit for 24 hours and play
blackjack what i love craps i love slots
yeah
i was a big poker player yeah i like
poker too what was the most she ever won
oh my god i mean on a slot machine five
grand six grand yeah on a cruise i want
a
shitload i won twenty were you working
the cruise or did you go on the cruise
ship
i've also gone and lost my pay within a
day or two
it's [ __ ] what work it also too when
you're if you lose if you lose
if you lose on a casino gig early and
you still gotta sit on the cruise of the
casino for the next three days it
[ __ ] sucks you lost your whole pay
for the week and you're
like hey i should do a joke about my
balls and i'm like
i have no money i'm being harassed by a
[ __ ]
like it's that's awesome oh man
yeah i haven't gambled in a long time
but i'm playing mohegan son
so am i at the end of the month when are
you doing it i'm going up with uh
version november 11th i'm there the week
before
and i'm like oh boy i'm just not doing
it i haven't done it in years
you stopped cold turkey i just got i
stopped
i had kids and i thought what am i doing
yeah like
you can't once you have kids you can't
bet thousands i mean it's crazy like
what was the most how much do you think
total you've lost
at one time on it's not a lot compared
to a lot of people but maybe three grand
but that was [ __ ] exciting that's
more than he made last year i'm telling
you that was
it but i'm i'm i'm crazy okay so i'm an
addict and i love the whole
you know the craziness of the gambling
but even if i'm up
i will gamble it away just so i feel
like [ __ ] i know that might sound crazy
to some people
because that's what i feel comfortable i
didn't feel worth it to leave with
stacks of money
putting it back i know it's not sad why
it's tough because i go
i know the sorrow of losing it and i go
i've left
the casino with no like completely
broken yeah i'm go i've lived
like i'm i woke up the next day so i'll
figure it out so
i'm okay with it and party it revels in
it a little bit right and then i'm like
i'm up so if i lose it i'll be even yes
it's crazy damage i know i'm damaged
i've been doing a lot of work on it but
that is it's not okay
it's crazy have you ever been to an otb
no okay
no you're a little classier
he came from jersey he thought he had a
friend there yeah everybody
too yeah never yeah it's crazy yeah
either he's like
[ __ ] goes no
hey what's up guys let's take a quick
second to talk about our brand new
sponsor ipvanish baby ipvanish is an
incredibly important tool that will help
you protect your privacy online which is
very
very important i don't know how you
spend your time online
what you do when you're online isn't my
business no or it's nobody else's i
don't want you peaking in my history
either you know what i mean no peaky
peaky
if you don't want cyber criminals to
steal your data or marketers to track
what you're buying you need
ipvanish ipvanish is a vpn
virtual private network that creates a
private connection from your computer
or phone or tablet to the internet which
protects your identity and
encrypts your data so nobody knows what
you're doing
gotta keep them guessing vpns are great
for protecting your data from hackers
especially when using public wi-fi that
isn't secure
with ipvanish your real ip address
disappears
so you can't be tracked online you'll
get fast unrestricted internet
they have more than 1 500 servers in
70 different countries get your
passports ready
so with ipvanish you're never going to
get stuck with a slow site or a video
that won't load
but what really makes ipvanish great is
that it's with vpn there's 24
7 customer support baby bottom line a
vpn is something everyone
will need soon enough so check out
ipvanish to start protecting your data
and privacy online today
and gang plans start at 3.25 cents per
month by going to ipvanish.com
backslash garbage that's 75 off their
regular price
just by going to ipvanish.com backslash
garbage
start protecting yourself online today
with ipvanish
now back to the show what were you a
good student what'd you get in your sats
i think i got like 12 something but that
was the second time the first time i got
like a thousand i
i i was that's still good tons of
tutoring you got a 620
for both he took it three times a
combined score
no what'd you get an 890 870. i still
got a
pretty good college that's good yeah no
i two years later
it's okay listen we all make mistakes
but you have your masters
no i i didn't get my masters i almost
got it but i
i did stand up like i just fell in love
with stan and i was like [ __ ] this
i hate school i probably had six months
left it was i i would have never used it
though
especially actually now i would because
there's coved so i need
i'm gonna have to work in a [ __ ] deli
i don't know what's gonna happen i know
yeah no i sure you could forge that
transcript you're right
no one's going but you know yeah if it's
no one's ever checked my transcripts
ever you're just like
hey people get caught they get busted
nah you're fine yeah i don't know let's
hope i don't have to do that i went to
the university of notre dame then
graduated to buy weed one week where did
you go
i went to weidner university i know
widener you do i think i performed there
is it in pennsylvania
yeah i think i performed there yes yeah
there were years where i did
tons of colleges yeah it was all right
it was a good school yeah good time
didn't you quit to like follow the stone
temple pilots or somebody you did
something outrageous
no i didn't go to like in the beginning
of lacrosse season you go to lacrosse
camp
it's like you know like like a
pre-season intensive and that's where
you like they set up the offense and the
defense for the year and all that [ __ ]
i didn't do that and i went to seattle
with my buddy because we were gonna move
to seattle in the summer
so we went out there for spring break to
scope it out
oh yeah do you know i played lacrosse in
high school yeah
and i um honestly that was the hardest
sport i've ever done
that in golf but that was i thought
lacrosse was
so hot golf wait how does golf get in
there i've tried golf and it just seems
oh like the skill oh yeah it's brutal
brutal
yeah absolutely but lacrosse is an
amazing sport
yeah it was fun all right finally
somebody has a little
kidney this is the third week lacrosse
has come up for him he's he's reveling
in it
got his letterman jacket on just gonna
go to the big game tonight
can i get an orange gatorade in here
some uh purple skittles
yeah all right let's get into a little
are you garbage
all right let's do it we got the sats we
know the background a little bit
yes yes um all right let's uh a little
bit now so you you live in long island
now
on long island right yeah i live on long
island is it a single family home you
live in there's an apartment a condo
what are we looking at i have a home
you have a single family just brought it
right before covington really yes
okay does that home have a garage yes
does that
garage have a refrigerator in it no oh
really wow growing up jersey the birds
always two houses most jews have
two fridges exactly because we're afraid
we're going to be taken away again
we take a lot of food buy them bulk
costco yeah
then why don't you have one now are you
going to get one do you think you just
bought the house
i mean like right before coving so and
we have a big fridge
okay yeah love a big fridge what brand
is it
um you got a viking or something not a
viking
frigidaire no
um i think it's it's a general lecture i
don't know it's a huge
fridge with a big freezer with different
the freezer at the bottom
and you open it like this
wait you open it like i just get the
freezer at the bottom yeah i just got
excited
yeah that might be the best fridge
anybody's had on the show that's [ __ ]
nice yeah that's a little bit
opens up like a rubik's cube [ __ ]
love it that's what my parents it's like
origami
yeah it's nice and the one side has that
little flap on it to keep everything
extra cool so you open it like that
yes it has flaps yeah that's clean
living right there
okay all right i like it but growing up
you did have two fridges
yes and in those refrigerators in the
garage was usually
what frozen dinners that have been made
meats breads cookies everything
everything
sodas you keep everything in a jewish
you don't throw anything out
yeah i swear it's crazy my bat mitzvah
cake is still intact
really no i didn't muzzle i binged on
that [ __ ]
yeah wait is that a thing to save a
little piece of yours yes oh it is
yeah i knew it was a wedding thing yeah
oh thank you so much
that was like an hour ago like a little
bit of cream please
i put an average no
i'll make you another one no don't worry
about it it's fine i'll drink it that's
it you're fired [ __ ]
mikey i'm nervous coming
i like how you put the screws to them i
like a little milk i put it in
i know cause i thought he was oh that's
a lot of cream
he cream this right now what did he jizz
in this
yeah if you want this you're so sweet i
yeah a little bit of cream is good just
because i don't we're going to pour it
on your crust i don't want to [ __ ] all
over again dude i've never seen you like
he's flustered
what no i love him he's great
when he was walking in behind me i said
jessica jessica kirsten's going to say
oh my god i love her oh yes you did
it was like i told him i told him bette
midler
you have a cute mustache you're very
cute that was awesome where the [ __ ] is
the coffee
zach braff wouldn't stand for this i
gotta call my [ __ ] brother in here
straighten you out you imagine if i
called him i'm doing a pot
they didn't even give me 20 grand do you
believe that
did you get the 20 g's for the thing
last night not 20 but
uh no we split a nice amount that's
great yeah there we go
yeah um i have a question
what is the length
of the inner circle of people
in your life that you would eat off
their plates
and before you answer that we didn't ask
it do you think you're garbage
do you think you're garbage oh that's
such a good question i mean that that is
probably so many meanings right like not
that i'm not trashy
i think i've acted like i'm garbage
but i don't think i am garbage yeah okay
i think you come from pretty good stock
pretty good stocks right i mentioned
country club dolphin lacrosse right
i've done things that are garbage sure
sure everybody rebels a little bit
you know yeah okay so back to my
original question yeah
explain it again whose plate what's the
limit of people's plate that you would
eat off of
like wife kids oh
neighbors no not neighbors
yeah she's not an animal also like
what's yours i want to know your answer
it's probably [ __ ] most of
yours i wouldn't eat from anyone's plate
that isn't in my
in immediate family okay that's the
correct answer yeah that means so that
means
wife kids i would eat off my siblings
plates or my parents or
okay but not my wife's siblings or my
wife's parents
okay not your in-laws all right with him
now
no okay no there's certain things in my
wife's that i won't even share
really yeah it's just drinks are a
little rough it depends what it is
salad is weird because stuff comes back
down after you
take the swig salads yeah i can't fight
there's like a piece of an olive
in my [ __ ] diet sprite i don't really
need that right now
i'm like right i'm about to go over the
blue cheese in the corner of your mouth
i did that to my dad one time by
accident at a uh at a family
party it was christmas eve i was all
smoked up
and i walked in like just this spread of
like
shrimp and [ __ ] crab cakes and
brownies
and i was i served all courses at the
same time
just dump it in a trough and let you
animals have at it
i've never been to any event where
there's been brownies and shrimp out at
the same time shrimp brownies
shrownies because i had them all
and i had this big frosty mug of beer
and i was taking big sips off of that
eating it and i put it down
and i turned around for a second and my
dad had picked it up and was starting to
drink it
and i was like dude i was eating all
kinds of things right tastes like he
drank from a fish tank
[Laughter]
by the way another question have you
ever owned a fish tank like a prop
when i was a kid not proper okay just
like a boat fish died every week
what was the pet situation growing up as
a whole oh god
well we had two outdoor cats mine was
named baby
that's original um and my sisters was
named gypsy and then we had a dog named
biff
i mean what a horrible name my dad tough
name yeah
the baby's the trashiest one at all no
it gets worse
and then um and then i had a cat
lulu and a cat kitty this is so
embarrassing and then i my ex and i
named our dog puppy i mean
you have to know i've been on drugs in
my life that i've named all these
things on the nouns yeah yeah yeah
contract was the next one i'm joking
um and then my and then
my wife i we i came into this animal
into the relationship was bailey and he
was awesome but
that's that's my pet okay as the pets
passed away when you were a kid
where would the bodies be disposed of um
at the the vet okay
i got a couple of dogs in my backyard no
we don't we don't do that
let's put a little grave a little cross
it's real bad
real real [ __ ] 21 gun salute yeah
flyover i was i was thinking about it
today my my parents did okay
but they came they were both really poor
my parents were okay and nobody teaches
you
that you got to act like generational
money
like refined you my parents were just
animals with
like they didn't know what to do it does
refine so they have all these like
general you know like if your dad had
money you're going to be a little bit
better
but my parents were just savages they
put it all in blooming onions
like outback steakhouse best with that
sauce never been to an outback you
believe that oh god you got to go
go now never been to an outback or a
benihana
oh my god you have to go to an outback
okay you like it
do you ever been to ruby tuesdays yeah
i've been roots
that's a classic salad bar you get like
seven meals
that's garbage yeah that's trash that's
i that's
i love the good salad yeah that's that's
gone right
there there'll be no more salad bars i
don't know there's a couple of hot bars
still floating around on some boats
no i haven't seen a lot of salad bars um
there's people on 23rd street eating
they out to eat
on the street at outback steakhouse
which boggles my mind
i've all like you've been pooped up for
so long yeah and
you can finally go to a restaurant and
you choose to eat on 23rd street because
that's
the outback is very fancy for some
people i know
that's tough though i'd rather what do
you want to go for the kids
anniversary outback that's that's where
all my mom's birthdays are
it's all they're they're garbage people
really that's for the people
that haven't her birthday is an outback
this is to put it this way
i what my i we they celebrated things
where we the kids didn't get invited
they went to outback we it was an
applebee's level
for the kids when they were out spending
a couple of bucks yeah they wanted those
they had applebee's
they wanted those signature cocktails
yeah
yeah flaming margaritas they would go to
the one and like it was in like the
parking lot next to like you know a
business complex
right across from right across from the
park is so [ __ ] depressing
and they think like yeah we got a nice
we went to that's like they'll still do
it
yeah it's so trashy can they bring
leftovers home
my mom's a big leftover gal but she's
also trash
so i think taking leftovers is a trash
move
i don't it depends where you go i if
you're i i feel like if you spend money
you should absolutely take stuff home
i'm not a
i don't disagree i just think it's right
you think it's not classy
taking home scraps is not a classic it's
not scraps
it's the rest of your meal we've been
over this especially if it's a good meal
yeah i'm not [ __ ] late i finish it
you don't have
who are we who are we fooling here you
haven't had [ __ ] leftovers in years
although we did see uh one of the
barstool guys uh this week
wrapped up like if he was after dinner
with a bunch of people
and took other people's leftovers home
in the same container
is he [ __ ]
[Laughter]
are you kidding me is that true are you
out to dinner with him no they were they
were
it's been this has been very posted the
leftover has been a very divisive thing
on our show and other people
i think that's insane yeah if you have a
ton of money and you're taking other
people's leftovers
yeah well not like stealing it but just
they didn't want it i still think that's
crazy yeah that's pushing it yeah she's
delicious classy
classy broad over here very classy so
far um i got one
is any of the tupperware at your house
currently stained red
yes is any of the tupperware at your
house currently old to go containers
like a thing of promise that's not me
that's my wife and yes probably
okay wait hold on that's not me i would
never keep that that's two separate
questions is it something that you
bought from the
like a like a promise container like uh
or anything
are you currently using anything that's
not a tupperware as tougher no
okay like my mine's big my mom's big on
like an old sock
a thing of margarine you open it up and
it's like gravy or something
a web i love that no i don't yeah oh you
don't reuse them
no plastic things that should just be
trashed see i love that go into my mom's
refrigerator and open up like a thing of
uh
breakstones cottage cheese with
pineapple because that's how they like
it
and there'd be like two or three
meatballs in there [ __ ] that's good
so i totally know what you're doing
that's trash
pop that right in the microwave sprinkle
a little acapella on there
yeah no i don't do that clean living
though i tell you one time i woke up and
i made it was like
ready to bot i was like hung over and
i'm like i'm gonna butter this bagel and
i opened it up and it was like
dripping i don't know what it was but it
was this price [ __ ] throw up all over
the
place
all over the counter he's got a real
thing with ambrosia was ambrosia
not mine but i married into that because
it's italian yeah yeah i love it
i remember somebody served it to me at a
graduation party one time i was like yo
tuts hit the bricks with whatever the
[ __ ] this is
it is like it's like they serve it with
the meat
that's that's the weirdest thing it's
gay
i don't even know what it is it looks
like mayonnaise with marshmallows
no it's not it's sour cream
it's sour cream coconut pineapple
walnuts
maraschino cherries with cherries in it
peaches people
put all kinds of [ __ ] and it sounds like
someone had to make a dessert and
didn't chop and they were like let's
just pull whatever we got marshmallows
oh do you like it what i love that and
some deviled eggs
i know me too i love coconut too
wait you don't like deviled eggs oh no
no jessica
i love deviled eggs i don't understand
them to be honest that hard boiled eggs
i can't wrap my head i
love harvey what what are you talking
about growing up if my mom didn't like
it she didn't she was a single mom she
didn't make it in the house so if she
didn't like it i didn't get introduced
until i was like 22. well all the all
the no way jose yeah
if it ain't scrambled i ain't touching
it yeah i know what you mean i grew up
with
some rotten food because my mom was busy
helping everybody so i
you know i would go for like sour cream
and it would be like goat cheese
yeah it was a lot go cheese to a kid
that might as well be acid i know
but that's very classy that you even had
goat cheese in your house as a kid
i don't think my parents even are aware
of what goat cheese is no
to this day i'm pretty sure my mom's
never had indian food too i was talking
about that before she's just it's like
potatoes and outback that's it
yeah you guys are it's like totally
american
yeah yeah it's american like real just
trash yeah that's bad
i'd love to see my mom sitting down
there with a nice a nice smear of
indian cuisine like trying to read the
menu my mom would be like do you have a
like where's the bloom and onions you
know
i'll have a gin and tonic absolute and
tonic
what's this tikka masala [ __ ]
you got a breaded cutlet can you make
that into a sandwich
can i get the chicken with no sauce just
the chicken
i saw somebody do this the other day
that i wanted to ask you um kippy would
get your input as well
in the grocery store okay how do you
feel about leaving the cart
and going out and doing a little thing
on your own and having the cart kind of
stuff it's in somebody's way
oh and it's out of your space i do it i
do it
and i've also grabbed other people's
carts about 400 times
and i'll walk away and be like did i
order like afro sheen
i pick out afro gene and like coconut
oil what is happening
who am i i've done that i've done that
so many times
taking somebody else's i'm so out of it
like trying to look for stuff and then
i'll just walk away and someone's like
excuse me
excuse me that's my card my baby's in
there miss
miss that's my child no it's a handicap
that's my scooter
i love looking at other people's carts
at the grocery store so do i see what
they got see what they got going on yeah
i always think i'm better than everybody
at the grocery store too i always feel
like i'm better
that way no there's people who are
better sometimes though they'll have
most of them all
and [ __ ] they don't you know i'm like
you get a life
that was something about waiting tables
too i agree i would like especially when
i worked
i worked at a bear burger for a little
while all right and i would listen to
the way people would get their burger
and if i thought that would sound pretty
tasty i would then order that later oh
that's cute so that's heart disease but
sure
no that's cute morbidly obesity oh
i get it um all right this is a big one
that uh
since we're talking about food if you
get takeout or delivery right and you're
at your house would take out a delivery
do you plate it on your own plate or do
you eat out of the
i played it that's class that's the
right move yeah
when i was from my 20s and 30s
now i i played it so if you guys are
home and you you guys have kids right
yeah how many do you have
i have 46 children no um i have i have
one with my ex who doesn't live with me
but lives right near me 14 year old and
then i have a
five-year-old they're all girls okay i
have a five-year-old you're not gonna
believe this and
twin eighteen-month-olds what i think i
didn't know that actually yeah
so you got a full house i have full
house so when you guys are all sitting
down to have dinner
if it's takeout you're taking it out and
you're serving it on the plates
yeah that's the way to do it that's
class but we will use paper plates like
we're not that's fine that's what
happens when you have kids you're like i
don't want to [ __ ] do dishes
i don't want to do anything but i also
find that i eat less if i take it out
and like
portion it because if i eat it from a
container it's
right out of the chinese container the
next day when i'm secretly binging
i love because in front of them i'm like
yeah i'll put some up but the next day i
just stand there with the
cold chinese food is one of my favorite
things ever it's great
yes because somebody asked on twitter uh
is it okay to eat cold
uh cold leftovers yes
and the way i look at it is if the food
was that good you can eat it cold
i love cold spaghetti so do i love cold
food too
not everyone likes that but i i do love
not a big cold guy
yeah i'm weird i know how much in fact i
don't like heating it up sometimes i
like it better cold yeah
like a meatball cold so good that's
gonna drag you down in the garbage
just a tiny bit though that's gonna be
tough she's pretty bold anything that i
do
is trash i've agreed with some stuff so
there's some trash there well the tv be
on while you guys have dinner
um that's hard now because i don't watch
tv now because
everything is i can't handle what's on
tv okay
um but yes i've always watched tv while
i eat
okay yeah um and you mentioned the paper
plates is it proper paper
is it like the more cardboard ones or is
it the styrofoam
no they're proper plate paper plates
nice
i mean if people come over i use regular
plates sure you're not an animal
jeez i mean if i came over to your place
in long island
i would expect the [ __ ] wait you mean
paper plates trying to get like a dollar
slice on like those kind of paper plates
yeah okay yeah all right not violent now
because i don't want to do the dishes
every night i mean i just you know but
are they the really thin ones we got to
use like two or three of them so it
doesn't leak
or they like that the the hearty one no
cottonelle makes this
they're pretty hearty okay you don't
have to use two i know exactly what
you're talking about they're not you buy
them in like 5 000
stacks and you just gotta like grab a
handful of them to eat a piece of pizza
oh yeah
half the stack yeah yeah you can if any
if your food has any moisture in it you
can't put it on there i know
yeah yeah you weigh so much stuff like
that like when i have a stack of napkins
like that i'm just like
me i know i do the same
thing dude if i have more than one roll
of paper towel in my house i'll just
wrap myself in it
i'm like i'm rich it's fine i do grab
like 50 now yeah that's savage oh my god
ah
all right we got to get you out of here
in a little bit here um i want to wrap
it up with a few of our standards
hold on hey i gotta call ya okay go
ahead fire away from does anyone in your
family ever appeared on the antiques
roadshow
no okay
have you ever taken the grease from your
face and put it in your drink to make
the foam go away
i have done that when i was drinking
beer yeah i mean yeah
i mean if she's doing it now that's a
problem but if she was in college
or whatever are you doing it now
take some of the cream out of this guy i
think mike already did that to your
coffee years but when i was
drinking in college i just wanted the
[ __ ] you gotta get it
in me yeah um have you ever used the
chili cheese machine at 7-eleven
yes when i've been drunk or high but
that's not a normal thing that i would
do
yeah has anyone in your family ever
owned a ronco showtime rotisserie cooker
and how do you feel in general about the
rotisserie chicken itself
i love rotisserie chicken but no no
gang baby no one has owned that but i
love fertilizer i've always wanted one
of those [ __ ] showtime rotisserie
said i didn't forget it baby
he's talking about what's his name mike
pompilo whatever is bronco
ronco yeah yeah ron pump ron popeel yeah
ron popeil with the yeah
rotisserie cooking i think he was
banging that lady that did the sh she
was an idiot he had [ __ ] she couldn't
believe anything she's like what
anything else what oh my god
he cooks chicken lady [ __ ] relax yeah
if yak now you get something else ladies
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh have you ever made this this came
from facebook have you ever made which i
was a big fan of have you ever made
nachos in the microwave
yes
anything with food i've done as a little
kid garbage that's being a food addict
i thought i was in cancun i was doing it
as a little kid
that's the putting a couple of tostitos
on a paper plate shredded cheese
breaking out some [ __ ] black olives
it's probably one of my favorite things
in the world and a cold can of coke
yes night yes good night i like when it
burns like
i love it yep homemade nacho salsa sour
cream ah
the best hogan's heroes goodbye
that's a [ __ ] nightmare that's that's
right it's like stuck to the paper plate
or whatever
one big nacho you don't do those you
don't do those in a fancy way yeah
you should be shocked you and you
shouldn't be doing that in front of
other people no
that's when no one's home or it's like
two in the morning or something
you don't show other people yeah that's
when mom's seeing a client
that's when that is
[Music]
all right let's do something want to do
some uh the normal ones i do out of here
i would like to know uh
growing up um where you served milk with
dinner
never bumped jewish we don't do that i'm
not saying it's right or wrong i like
actually
what but no we didn't you don't you
don't mix
milk with meat a lot of people we're not
we weren't growing we didn't grow up
kosher but
like it's very uncommon for jewish
people to drink milk with their meal
because they're a little more refined
yeah what about the butter when you were
growing up where was that in the fridge
or on the counter oh
that's a good question it was in the
fridge but i i but
now i'm around it on the counter because
really yeah i'm turning the corner
myself i thought it was the most insane
thing to keep butter out
no but everybody everybody says it's
great in fact i just
uh cooked my kid a grilled cheese
yesterday and then and it had been
sitting out for a while and it was
amazing just just yup spreads right over
there
we found out unsalted you can lit you
have to keep that's like cooking butter
oh
unsalted you have to keep in but the
salt salted butter you can keep out
because
i don't know that i'm personally
offended by unsalted butter me too and
i've been conned by my mother
a couple of times where that was i went
in with a [ __ ] english muffy
to [ __ ] hook it up with some butter
and it was unsalted i know
but then i pour salt on it the best is
break stones with so i just love it
yeah the blue package oh yeah yeah the
whole container
oh man they know what they're doing oh
she's got some garbage tendencies i know
that's right it's gonna be hard garbage
side to me yeah she's too she's
yeah but i don't see two refined i don't
think those charges are gonna stick yeah
no
yeah um i got one have you ever used
bounty wrinkle release
no that's trash ever use the atm just to
check your balance
[Laughter]
no no is it a way that that's the first
thing they ask you do you want to check
your balance no
i want [ __ ] crazy yes stop asking me
questions yes
um do you get cash back when you make a
purchase yeah that was my next question
that's a very good you guys have really
good questions um
i have but i don't normally do that no i
mean i've maybe done it
a handful of times what was the most
amount that you took out
a hundred a hundred she's got a little
bit of cash she's friends with deniro
by the way tell him i said what up
that's ballsy though going to the
checkout at the grocery store let me get
a hundred
well i mean i i don't i don't even think
a lot of places let you do that but but
i have done that i mean i've gotten 20
minutes or yeah
i used to be a cashier and people would
do it all like regularly but at some
places like at 7-elevens you can only
get 10 bucks or something it's like what
yeah that's like crackhead stuff yeah
that's depressing
you ever go to an atm when they let you
take five bucks out
when it's tens i'm [ __ ] furious yeah
cause like where were you in my 20s and
now it's like i don't want to be walking
around with tens
yeah that looks real shady it does six
hundred dollars and tens on it
cops ask questions you know what i mean
they're not dumb um
since it's the halloween season and i
think this is something that uh
character is judged upon what is your
favorite
candy bar oh that's a good question too
and there is a right do i have to come
up with one
top three top three candy bars reese's
peanut butter
cups that's number one hundred percent
that's classic are the best
twix okay lady after my own heart love
twix
i love score bars i love toffee coverage
it's a score
do you know what i'm talking about
do you like them dude you me and my dad
i think are the only three people
no i know other people that is an old
school dad
yes those are rolos i love kit kats
kit cats i love rollers i'm gonna keep
naming them
i remember my brother my brother used to
get rolos i'd be like what are you a
hundred
dollars what the [ __ ] eats rolling foil
like what the [ __ ] was this
what's the one with peanuts and raisins
that's trash chunky
yeah oh dude what you call me
chunky's all right that's a real it's a
real low quality chocolate yeah but when
you get to the raisin with the chocolate
it's nice
i don't even think i've seen what it is
a score bar is like a heath bar it's
toffee on the inside it's made by the
hershey company
it's it's it's it's it's it's good it's
pitched to a higher income demographic
basically it was supposed to be classy
it's one of my dad's favorites i mean i
love snickers milk i love all of them
charleston chews i like everything
a frozen charleston chew have you ever
had that
no put one of the vanilla from frozen
freezers and candy
chocolate i can't even [ __ ] talk but
just eat it
trust me i got it so good i started
putting uh
i haven't started that's all right let's
back up this summer
we put sour patch i was trying to hide
sour patches
from my niece and nephew and i put them
in the freezer amazing and i [ __ ] got
into them
oh man i get like two weeks vacation
yeah unreal
i've done the same thing they're amazing
that's a that's a popular thing actually
i know a lot of people who have that i
know it's something i should not have
discovered in my mid 40s at that 400
pounds i can tell you that
you're not 400 he's not not 400 pounds
no he's not 400 pounds i'm 400
no you're not i'm creeping he's for sure
he admits
openly admits 350. so real which with
the fat guy whatever he opened and it
hits you add seventy five
after painting it after a bad weekend he
could be
he could be four bills and never ask a
fat guy when's the last time he ate
because it'll always be a lie that's my
joke i used to be fat and i had some
good fat laying and i lost weight and he
was
he's been itching for it itching to
steal i got my hands on the material
like four years he's like let me use
that bit let me use that
i use it on the road can get you heckled
at parks yeah use it on the road
i'll use it somebody yells on the back
hey that's a kippy
[ __ ] just run off stage the jig's up
ah all right all right you got one more
all right i got one ketchup after it's
opened does it go in the refrigerator or
the cabinet
fridge glass yeah the last question i
have goes
goes along the same thing about the
sharing of the food but this is a little
bit different
now you might be out with like another
couple or it could be a business dinner
um or some extended family or just
friends
in that situation do you jessica kirsten
share a dessert will you share a dessert
with friends sure yes
yes yeah i'm big i got big into like if
they
you know if there's four of you yeah you
go oh give us and there's like three
desserts or whatever
go give us one of each and they all just
kind of do a business
yeah so that doesn't gross you out no
just because you like you just take a
piece and you can be tactical where you
go a little bit you have to mouth kiss
them but
guess what if it were ice cream or like
sorbet i wouldn't do it
yeah it's yes ice cream's tough it has
to be like
it has to be a long dessert yeah like a
churro
you're both eating one end because big
ice teaspoons
yeah oh that's pretty classy right there
that's all i got
yeah my official verdict is you're all
class
oh last night there you go
get it going baby are most people that
no most people are
pure animals garbage animals comics
mind we get answers where i'm like
really we've gotten people who are like
i haven't brushed
one thing is like hey do you brush your
teeth in the shower do you by the way no
because you're [ __ ] classy that's why
we asked one kid he goes i haven't
brushed my teeth in like
six months do you rinse off in the
shower
rinse off yeah that's the turmeric i
don't know
what does that mean well i don't know
you one time you said to me i'll just
rinse off okay so i call that uh i'm
gonna take a body shower
yeah you make it seem like you just jump
in there and get wet and jump out
i don't know what first of all i
literally i don't know what you're
talking about you're the one that said
it to me it was it was a few months ago
it's stuck in my brain
you said i took a shower and rinsed off
maybe and i thought it was like a
shorter version of a shower well what
are you rinsing off
i would think like what was on you that
you're gonna go in full tilt
yeah i go in i might not shampoo right
because i gotta keep i gotta you know i
gotta keep the seedlings going pretty
well but
i'll do a bot i always do the body you
know but i don't yeah you know it might
just be a quickie too just right
yeah hit the parts that matter you know
right around the bases and keep it
moving
around the base yeah i find i got it i
got when i go in i gotta do
everything because i have like a like a
half a day shelf life
just i smell like a pirate ship well
that's
that's a lot of booty have you smelled a
lot of butter
he's actually been in the caribbean once
or twice no i think it's important to
what you know and
some people yeah i it also like i feel
like vegetarians and people that eat
really well
don't have to shower as much yeah don't
you
yeah i think it's like no i think bigger
people
wear the days worse on them a little bit
but also what you eat
oh first like
those are so good we've talked about it
which all right
all right one more then we gotta get out
of what's your favorite fast food
restaurant i think burger king
okay i love wendy's too yeah one of
these love wine
classic there's something about wendy's
yeah yeah
no wendy's is awesome it is
wendy's fan how do you feel about
chick-fil-a i i won't eat there because
they hate games oh that's right
i know that sounds stupid but no fight
your fight i get it
i know it's like i just have these weird
principles sometimes and i just
i don't know yeah no because you know
why because probably the people that
made those rules are getting head
in a [ __ ] you know hole in the wall
like it just makes me crazy how about
popeyes
love popeyes yeah they're popular
popeyes everybody long john silver's
love i love but that's
he's a big ljs guy yeah that's a rough
one like when i eat that it's
yeah like doing all these weird places
on the road there's
they pop up long john silver's back at
the hotel what about arby's
dirty but i i've never been in an arby's
and been like oh you guys take you know
this is a tight ship
every year there's a layer of grease and
everything i will not do white castle
there's a couple in new york and you go
in it's like oh
yeah it's tough they don't even care
she's like there's only two of you you
don't have to keep you know
it's not like there's five thousand
[ __ ] white castles around you gotta
stay on top of there's one right down
the street from me on long island
and it's packed yeah the drive-through
is packed every night
it just makes me feel fat till i'm
ordering like 47 hamburgers it's like i
don't just give me two big ones i'm
going to call it
a mattress full of hamburgers i'll take
the 30 rock
yeah that's fine
jessica thank you so much for coming in
and sit with me thank you this was so
much fun i'm glad we finally made it
work
100 classes you're adorable you guys are
an adorable
i love it i love the whole thing is
there anything out there you'd like the
folks to know what anything you got
coming up the road
to this to that depends when this is
coming out this will be out
awesome so i'll be i'll be at mohegan
sun yeah the last weekend of the month
i'll be in
um jersey on friday night and i'll be in
in flemington new jersey friday night
and i'll be in at souljalls in
pennsylvania saturday night
and it's all listed on my social media
all right check her out
she's you're hilarious thank you so much
first of all she kills harder than
anybody in the city if you have not seen
jessica on stage doing yourself a
[ __ ] favor
thank you and the videos you post online
are so [ __ ] funny thank you
what do you got for him just as always
at cameron comedy on all social media
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes youtube and gas digital
check it out thank you yes sir we love
you guys at a trolley on ice on twitter
foldygrams on instagram
uh we will see you guys next week peace
peace